[Musique]
Bruno Drouillard et Patrick angona merci
de nous recevoir chez vous alors je
vends oui merci de venir jusqu'à nous
aussi oui merci
et on va on va parler surtout de
irrésistible Offenbach puisque c'est
votre dernière création qu'on peut voir
actuellement au théâtre de Passy à Paris
exactement de depuis jeudi dernier donc
jusqu'au 28 mai du mercredi au samedi
21h et le dimanche après-midi à 16h
alors mise en scène d'une très grande
miteuse en scène qui Anne bourgeois
c'est la première fois que qu'on
travaille avec absolument on avait très
envie et puis là ça c'est fait et c'est
une femme qui a une qui est prestigieuse
parce que dans le métier elle a déjà
deux Molières elle a un an fou et on
était même un peu impressionné de la
rencontrer
mais je peux vous dire qu'elle fait
bosser les comédies
de toutes les distribution tout à
l'heure mais Offenbach c'est Jean-Paul
faré c'est Jean-Paul fares c'est le
choix de Dan il a déjà travaillé trois
fois avec elle d'ailleurs aussi
Jean-Paul forêt il joue du piano il joue
voilà et puis bah ça tombe bien pour un
compositeur presque et puis c'est un
homme talentueux il a eu aussi trois
nominations Molière et c'est tout de
suite investi dans la pièce mais il faut
avouer qu'il est aussi très bien entouré
parce qu'on a six comédiens de
performance
la fille de Jean-Michel rime oui
je mange Daniel chocolat rideau alors la
fille
elle a un talent particulier avec Cyril
parce qu'elle elle est comédienne mais
elle est aussi professeur de franche
cancan à Montmartre et là c'est idéal
parce que c'est une des surprises
c'est une comédienne professeure de
French Concorde elle cherche partout
hein les talents et puis vous disiez
David le rock aussi qu'on a eu dans
notre précédente pièce qui était les
tontons farceurs avec Philippe
Chevallier et Nathalie marquay-perneau
qui a fait un tournage télé qui a fait
énormément
c'est à peu près votre votre 40e pièce à
vous et puis à vous deux c'est la
combientième
1999 une trentaine trentaine
la pièce se concentre sur les 10
dernières années juste un petit peu
c'est sur deux périodes un petit peu la
fin de sa vie et 10 années avant les
années à peu près 1870 ou la guerre va
éclater avec la Prusse ah oui il a moins
de succès en France il a des dettes de
jeu et il est un peu catastrophe et
moins d'imagination pour écrire et voilà
par contre il a énormément de succès en
Angleterre donc il a un petit peu comme
dit Patrick un passage à vide et puis il
va rebondir et en plus
hors tension Neder avec qui il est fâché
c'est la cantatrice qui est sa maîtresse
voilà mais qu'il est plus à ce moment-là
parce qu'elle a beaucoup de monde autour
d'elle
quoi exactement il y a un moment aussi
d'ailleurs c'est très amusant parce
qu'on a un moment aussi un peu à la une
première de d'une opérette et on sait
tous les rois les princes de de du monde
qui viennent l'admirer et plus ou moins
très proche d'aller on va dire et alors
donc
c'est dans la deuxième période de cette
vie donc c'est un artiste comblé enfin
voilà au succès et qui dirige des
Bouffes Parisiens oui complètement mais
qui est un petit peu en difficulté à ce
moment-là donc et après on reviendra 10
ans après
ou à nouveau et triomphe
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu plusieurs
périodes dans la vie d'Offenbach
quel je me souviens moi d'un feuilleton
qui avait la télévision sur Offenbach je
crois que c'était Michel Serrault qui
oui c'est Michel Serrault et le
réalisateur c'était Michel Boiron dans
les années 78 il y avait un monde fou
dans on l'a vu alors on a écrit la pièce
avant mais le hasard veut que je l'ai
trouvé à la FNAC ce DVD je l'ai acheté
pour voir et je me suis aperçu avec
Patrick on s'est aperçu qu'on s'est pas
trop te tromper en écrivant un passage
de sa vie on a essayé de faire des
recherches quand même c'est oui bien sûr
c'est un sacré personnage
il savait pas trop ce qu'il devait faire
je crois qu'il est parti en Angleterre
et puis et puis et puis après 10 ans
après c'est la fin de sa vie et le
hasard veut aussi qu'il
est mort à Paris mais il a passé presque
toute la fin de sa vie à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye au Pavillon Henri
IV c'est absolument et c'est vrai oui
donc c'est activé d'adoption
non non je voulais dire je pense que
à cette folie il nous restitue
complètement je pense oui il y a quelque
chose
c'est probable c'est un génie
dans le talent oui dans le talent mais
il était aussi critiqué par ce qui est
qui trouvaient qu'il était trop
fantaisiste dans cette pièce qui est une
pièce avec des surprises très heureuse
tout autour on peut pas tout divulguer
scan bourgeois on a trouvé plein mais
c'est quand même une vraie pièce de
théâtre très écrite et puis et puis on
voit le tout tout le talent de de
compositeur aussi voilà il y a eu des
réorchestration je peux pas révéler
d'une ou deux minutes par-ci par là pour
pour donner aussi le des choses
magnifiques dans la pièce pour
argumenter en fait oui parce que
évidemment les oeuvres qu'on connaît pas
et puis il y a aussi des morceaux qui
sont absolument fabuleux qui sont très
drôles avec avec des librettistes qui
travaillaient à deux comme vous si oui
mais non exactement
une jeune fille et on se demande de
pourquoi il a proposé enfin voilà il y a
tout une petite anecdote dessus non ils
étaient très complices c'était toute
façon c'était le beau côté de la vie
parisienne de l'époque c'était une part
d'insouciance une part
de la fête oui
on est sous Napoléon III en gros
après il y a peu c'est une période un
peu plus difficile mais qui va pas durer
mais mais c'est vrai que en plus il a
tiré énormément tous les publics le
public bourgeois le public est aussi
populaire et les gens dans la rue voilà
et puis sur scène il mettait il mettait
de la joie aux gens il a porté du
bonheur du bonheur oui mais même la
musique il suffit d'écuser la musique de
d'Offenbach on est joyeux quoi elle
plait toujours parce qu'on a commencé
mercredi dernier on a regardé les gens
qui sont venus c'était la première hein
à Paris donc oui le 6 avril on a été
stupéfait la moitié de la clientèle à
20-30 ans 40 ans et son viennent de voir
alors qu'on est dans le 16e une
clientèle des fois un petit peu plus de
théâtre parfois plutôt
parce qu'il le découvre parce que ben
voilà il a intemporel c'est un magicien
comment vous avez eu l'idée de de faire
une pièce sur sur Offenbach alors
souvent les idées viennent
[Musique]
toute seule un détail nous accroche et
on s'attarde dessus là on avait écouté
Offenbach
en sur un disque
à côté et puis on se dit mais on devrait
faire raconter la vie on n'a jamais
c'est notre première pièce historique
une deuxième après toujours
contemporaine dans tous les styles de
comédie
et là boulevard même des pièces
poétiques des pièces
sociales écologique oui voilà et puis là
on a eu en écoutant un petit peu la
musique on s'est dit pourquoi on
rencontre raconterait pas la vie d'un
monsieur comme lui et puis dès le
lendemain on prenait la plume Patrick et
moi et Patrick en plus écrit des
chansons et sociétaires des sociétaires
des poètes français
c'est un peu ça l'amour c'est un chemin
qui devient commun voilà c'est bizarre
et alors donc pour finir avec les
résistible au fundback c'est donc au
théâtre de passer jusqu'au 28 mai avec
cette avec cette distribution formidable
cette mise en scène date bourgeois et
c'est vrai que c'est ça fait partie
comme ça est-ce que c'est votre but au
fond de dire
on peut à la fois apprendre des choses
et s'amuser complètement
surtout aujourd'hui parce que on est ici
derrière la télévision on a que des
choses dramatiques des films policiers
ont vécu en voilà sur toutes les chaînes
tous les jours ah oui c'est effrayant
certaines chaînes on se dit mais quand
est-ce qu'ils vont arrêter alors ils
font de l'audience parce que les gens
savent pas toujours regarder ou quoi le
soir ils allument mais quel dommage qui
nous passe pas plus de communie parce
que dès qu'il passe une comédie elle
fait quand même une très belle audience
certains films de cinéma voir des
fictions que peuvent tourner certaines
chaînes mais ils n'en font pas assez moi
c'est c'est un truc qui me révolte un
peu puisque vous parlez de télévision
j'ai cru comprendre que c'est grâce à la
télévision vous êtes venus au théâtre
à cette émission mythique s'appelait au
théâtre ce soir de pierre sabag à moi
c'est complètement ça j'avais 10 ans la
mission a commencé en 66 si j'ai bonne
mémoire il a fini en 84 j'ai essayé de
tous les vendredis c'était le bonheur de
se retrouver en famille avec ma mère mes
frères et sœurs parfois mes
grands-parents
c'était le vendredi
et costume
qu'on a connu les gens de notre
génération évidemment se souviennent de
des noms de Rogers parce que ça revenait
toutes les semaines quel que soit la
pièce était toujours des cordes Aurélien
c'est et comme ça
[Musique]
et beaucoup de succès et cette demeure
une référence d'ailleurs alors ce qui a
d'amusant c'est que en écrivant des
comédies Patrick et moi on a cherché
tout de suite à voir tous ces comédiens
qu'on a aimé d'une époque et on a eu la
chance de connaître des gens comme
Georges Descrières avec Doris on a fait
trois pièces c'était le bonheur
extraordinaire pierre de risques oui on
est Christian
humour noir qui était à précurseur par
rapport à des gens comme comme Laurent
Ruquier même à l'émission
mais on a eu Christian marin qui est à
Monsieur formidable et puis on a fait
aussi alors là
Claudia qu'on a eu tellement de monde
jacques-claude
mais si les gens veulent regarder Bruno
druart.com il verront toutes les
certaines affiches et surtout tous les
noms on était hyper gâtés
voilà on a un chien si vous l'entendez
on entend il a le droit hein il y a pas
de raison
il est très beau en plus oui il
ressemble à un renard un peu donc oui
cette influence ça influence alors
est-ce que parfois on a pensé que ce
théâtre qui est de boulevard était un
peu dépassé est-ce que c'est est-ce que
il faut le moderniser aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'il faut pour le rendre
visible aujourd'hui moderniser je sais
pas parce que en province on rencontre
énormément de succès les gens ont besoin
de voir ce type de spectacle
ils attendent deux semaines avant le
spectacle deux semaines après ils ont
pas encore sur les mains sur les marchés
vraiment on rencontre un très large
public en province mais il faut quand
même dire une chose pardon c'est que
voiture a évolué on fait plus tout à
fait les boulevards par exemple qu'on
faisait dans les années 60 ça a duré
2h30 ils font 1h30 et l'écriture est
plus plus moderne plus il y a plus nous
on a travaillé ça parce qu'il faut
beaucoup de mouvements des répliques
plus courtes et puis des personnages
Peter le théâtre que faisait un peu Jean
Lefebvre et hélas dépasse j'en sais rien
en tout cas voilà provisations
je sais pas si aujourd'hui encore on
vient voir un comédien on va pouvoir
plutôt voir une pièce mais en même temps
un comédien comme Jean Poiret à la même
époque que je viens de faire c'était la
classe bien sûr vous aviez d'autres moi
j'ai adoré François Perrier par exemple
François férié j'aimais beaucoup y jouer
les pièces de Françoise Dorin par
exemple c'était très intéressant mais
beaucoup de pièces ont vieilli
malheureusement
exceptionnel parce qu'il y avait il y
avait un une culture française aussi qui
est trouvé dedans
baisser c'est vrai donc sur ce sur ce
théâtre là c'est vrai que vous avez
raison de dire voilà le public adore ça
et il y a une chose sur laquelle je
voudrais insister parce que on en parle
jamais c'est que vos pièces une
quarantaine de pièces tout au lieu de de
succès et beaucoup sont prises par des
troupes amateurs aussi alors ça c'est
très important énormément il y a une
chose il a une chose qu'il faut poser
notre
plus grande satisfaction c'est d'être
pris sur les planches par des compagnies
amateurs des gens qui font leur décolle
leur costume qui met toute leur passion
dans la création alors il y a des
librairies comme le libérez théâtrale
voilà où on trouve les œuvres qui sont
complètement les connaît bien on a aussi
la librairie de la traverse à Nice qui
est très importante qui édite qui nous
édite mais qui est dit aussi ericassous
des grands auteurs voilà et alors ce qui
est intéressant
c'est un petit peu le petit plus c'est
qu'on a écrit quelques pièces où il y a
plus de femmes que d'hommes il y a peu
d'auteur pour les femmes du coup les
troupes amateurs en France il y a
beaucoup plus de dames que de messieurs
et alors par exemple on a une qui
s'appelle parfum et suspicion mais ça
fait 10 ans que 15 ans elle avait été
créé par Marie-Paule Belle entre autres
et elle elle est jouée partout tout le
temps et à l'étranger aussi comme après
dire que maintenant les pièces au
théâtre plus de 3 acteurs les les
directeurs font un peu
peur peuvent se permettre d'avoir une
grande distribution
non parce que certaines trucs amateurs
sont vraiment formidables absolument
elles ont des niveaux professionnels
très important le théâtre amateur et
puis ça prouve l'engouement du théâtre
social qui sont un peu
isolés géographiquement alors je parle
comme ça de Flers ses cahiers V ou
barriers crédit parce que
ils écrivaient à quatre mains comme vous
il y a pas beaucoup d'enfants il y en a
quelques-uns il y a ceux qui sont très
connus évidemment comment on fait
alors Bruno le socle de notre
collaboration et moi je tourne autour
d'accord alors si vous voulez
de son côté ou non moi je j'ai écrit
l'histoire comme ça d'affilée et ensuite
Patrick rajoute plein de petites choses
ça peut être une chanson un poème ça
peut être certaines répliques il trouve
très souvent les titres et donc voilà on
est complice à ce niveau là mais c'est
je fais si vous voulez le de A à Z un
petit peu le squelette tout ce qu'on
veut mais avec certaines il y a déjà les
dialogues mais après on reprend 4 5 fois
une pièce alors le plus grand le plus
grand des hasards c'est que les pièces
peut-être qui sont les plus fortes chez
nous c'est celle qui ont été écrit les
plus vite
il y en a qui ont été faits en trois
semaines et ça on en revient pas mais on
était tellement passionnés on savait
plus s'arrêter rrêter et quand vous avez
une idée vous allez jusqu'au bout
forcément ou parfois ça vous arrive
d'abandonner
deux fois ou trois fois
et en général on va jusqu'au bout
et on va on a écrit notre pièce on est
en train de faire la distribution qui va
être vraiment bien ça va être notre
deuxième pièce historique elle va
s'appeler mademoiselle Georges et c'est
la célèbre tragédienne de la connue
française sous Napoléon 1er là mais
c'est une comédie avec tous les rapports
de jalousie de mesquinerie à la commune
française donc on va bien s'amuser
un travail de documentation
mais c'est passionnant ça
la première pièce ça s'appelait Janine
Truchot c'est ça j'allais être chaud a
disparu on a je connaissais pas Patrick
j'ai mis 10 ans pour la montée on la
coproduites on l'a fait au théâtre
d'Edgar elle a fait 600 représentations
tellement ça a bien marché j'avais pris
trois jeunes trois jeunes femmes un gars
c'est compliqué de commencer
petit conseil aux jeunes auteurs vous
qui ont envie de se lancer au théâtre
faut persévérer quoi alors où c'est dans
les il faut je pense qu'il faut souvent
trouver des comédiens de talentueux un
Patrick et essayer de monter par
soi-même et le présenter dans les cafés
théâtres les petits théâtres et cetera
mais c'était certainement plus facile à
dans les années 80-90 aujourd'hui oui je
vois on connaît pas le docteur qu'il n'y
arrive pas il y a une économie du
théâtre qui est compliqué du club privé
notamment enfin qui est compliqué qui
fait que voilà on privilégie des pièces
à deux acteurs
ce qui va on en a écrit une exploitation
de la création devient très compliquée
en France
elle dépend de considérations qui nous
échappe absolument oui ça c'est pas le
problème des auteurs écrire une pièce à
deux personnages c'est très difficile on
en a fait une qui a vraiment bien marché
et on était heureux ça s'appelait
station bonne nouvelle on a eu c'est la
dernière pièce que jouer Charlotte
valandre donc en 2019 juste avant le
covid avec Christian Vadim un couple qui
était merveilleux qui a été aussi on le
voit sur comediplus mais c'était du
bonheur et on avait un bon metteur en
scène Didier Bringard c'est important
les metteur en scène
c'est important là c'est un bourgeois
ça s'appelle irrésistible Offenbach et
ses produits par les lucioles qui avec
qui on travaille depuis 13 ans parce que
ils aiment bien ce qu'on fait et donc du
coup on est un petit peu fidélisé par
rapport à eux qui nous demandent chaque
année une pièce c'est au théâtre de
Passy jusqu'au 28 mai puis après
on va faire un an et demi de tournée ça
va aller jusqu'à fin 2024 vous allez de
temps en temps et tourner vous allez
voir
de santé parce que Bruno ne conduit pas
mais on nous appelle après chaque
représentation pour nous dire comment ça
s'est passé on suit du coeur et et de
loin on nous envoie aussi des petits
films des choses comme ça mais on a des
comédiens on essaie d'avoir aussi des
comédiens non seulement talentueux mais
mes chaleureux et donc du coup
on fidélise un peu voilà
c'est très important ce qui fait que
ça marche allez bon on va saluer alors
hein
merci beaucoup
[Musique]